[Musica]
con l'avvento della produzione di massa
di dispositivi elettrici ed elettronici
un nuovo problema iniziato a far
capolino come facciamo a rendere tutte
queste cose che utilizziamo tutti i
giorni i semplici e comprensibili a
chiunque gameplay è un termine
bellissimo che mi piace molto perché
rende l'idea di quali sono le
aspettative del cliente
noi stessi vogliamo comprare un
dispositivo ad esempio collegarlo al
nostro computer e iniziare a utilizzarlo
il prima possibile e questo deve
funzionare la tecnologia ha origine
sulla piattaforma media nel 1986
ma all epoca era chiamata auto config
successivamente nel 1990 una tecnologia
molto simile venne utilizzata sui
computer apple e successivamente sui
computer ibm compatibili
il vero e proprio termine plug'n'play
venne utilizzato per la prima volta nel
1993 alla windows hardware conference
quando pensiamo a queste parole
plug'n'play la prima cosa che ci può
venire in mente è ad esempio una
chiavetta usb da collegare al computer
deve funzionare una stampante lo
colleghiamo al computer e deve stampare
magari uno schermo stessa cosa come
facciamo a spiegare la banalità dietro
questo gesto collegare e utilizzare
subito un dispositivo
dietro questa banalità c'è un mondo che
noi neanche immaginiamo che è fatto di
pura magia nera perché appunto più una
cosa è facile e semplice da utilizzare
per l'utente più il lavoro che c'è
dietro da parte degli sviluppatori che
hanno cercato di coprire tutti i
possibili casi di uso di un dispositivo
per fare in modo che l'utente qualunque
cosa faccia questa cosa funzioni ma i
corner kate come suggerisce la parola
sono sempre dietro l'angolo
cercando di spiegarvi il concetto
prendendo da un po alla lontana alcune
prese elettriche nel mondo tipo quella
le mie spalle oltre a sembrare delle
bellissime faccine sorridenti sono
paralizzate questo cosa vuol dire vuol
dire che hanno un verso di inserimento
perché se io per qualche motivo
inserirsi la spira nella presa in
maniera sbagliata qualcosa di brutto
potesse potrebbe succedere quindi
abbiamo pensato come facciamo a
risolvere il problema perché l'utente
compro dispositivo e non legge il
manuale di istruzioni a meno che non è
un mobile ikea perché siamo costretti a
farlo quindi fin da piccoli abbiamo
utilizzato questo fantastico giochino di
legno che consisterà inserire le formine
al posto giusto quindi momento il
quadrato nel quadrato il cerchio e cioè
che il drago nel triangolo non posso
sbagliare
tecnicamente quindi abbiamo deciso di
utilizzare lo stesso principio per per
le prese elettriche abbiamo inserito
delle limitazioni meccaniche quindi la
presa
entra solo in un verso perché dall'altra
parte non ci entro semplicissimo in
italia invece ad esempio come in altri
paesi nel mondo abbiamo deciso che
questa limitazione della polarizzazione
della presa elettrica era meglio proprio
toglierla togliere il problema alla
radice e quindi non le prese elettriche
non sono paralizzate penso che
specificatamente in italia questa cosa
sia stata fatta perché l'italia non
riesce a mettere il quadrato nel cerchio
a pressione e quindi abbiamo detto
togliamo il problema proprio alla radice
infatti sono convinto che voi o qualcuno
che conoscete almeno una volta nella
vita
voi siete riusciti a inserire la presa
tedesca senza utilizzare adattatore
perché
decimo che sarà mai spingo entra manca
la terra non fatelo ok quindi questo
plug and play che cos'è un concetto
molto vago perché appunto noi persone
che fanno dispositivi per la gameplay
devono riuscire a dare all'utente
un'esperienza d'uso il più semplice
possibile
questo come
ecco come lo possiamo fare lo possiamo
fare andando a creare dei tool molto
complessi che riescono a consentire
all'utente di avere appunto a
disposizione questi questa tipologia di
strumenti voi direte cosa sa cosa vuol
dire questo
ad esempio la porta usb ok sempre
rimanendo nel tema delle connessioni
sono convinto che tutti
giulio questa mattina anche ora
confermato da inserire la chiavetta usb
nel suo computer e per farla funzionare
l'ha inserita almeno tre volte perché
l'ha inserita e non andava la girata
l'ha inserita non andava
lari girata verso che aveva provato
all'inizio stranamente ha funzionato
pazzesco 53 cento di possibilità ci ha
provato tre volte quindi come cosa è
successo ingegneri anche a cui succede
questa cosa
stanchi di dover fare queste cose molto
complesse queens e trovare sto problema
matematico di inserire una roba tre
volte quando dovrebbero bastare al
massimo due hanno deciso di inventare il
connettore usb c perché il conduttore
queste bici non ha un verso
l'inserimento cioè qualunque lo metto
prima botta è sempre giusto il
bellissimo
funziona tutto quindi abbiamo deciso di
utilizzare le porte usb c ovunque perché
è il connettore bellissimo quindi porte
usb c ovunque computer compatti perché
molto più piccolo abbiamo detto andiamo
così perché così la gente non deve
impazzire eva tranquilla ovviamente però
c'è la cosiddetta legacy cioè io ho dei
dispositivi vecchie che non hanno questo
nuovo connettore quindi cosa devo fare
consentire alla gente di utilizzare
questa nuova tecnologia anche sui
dispositivi vecchi quindi come faccio
con gli adattatori cioè la vita in fama
e ricky ha un computer usb c come me che
deve magari collegare diverse cose su
macchinari vecchi e va in giro con la
valigia piena di dongle perché devo
attaccare il monitor adattatore da cai
cavo ethernet attuatore poi ci sono i
bellissimi compattissimi adattatori che
hanno tutto insieme
lascio immaginare che
che bello ok poi però come facciamo a
spiegare il perché quando noi
attacchiamo qualcosa funziona subito a
me piace utilizzare una similitudine un
po estrema che però rende bene l'idea
secondo me quando noi colleghiamo
qualcosa al computer e questo funziona
avviene uno scambio di informazioni
immenso in pochissimo tempo ed è un po
come quando noi incontriamo una persona
che non l'abbiamo mai visto in vita
nostra siamo colpiti da un colpo di
fulmine e ci sembra di conoscere la
perfezione quella persona che tutto
funziona con un meccanismo ben oliato
poi vi posso parlare anche di un'altra
tipologia di di plug and play che entro
il gameplay che magari non conoscete che
spero si scatenerà una curiosità quando
uscire da qui è un'altra tipologia di
braghin play che vi introdurlo
utilizzando un proverbio perché spesso e
volentieri si dice che chi non ha il
pane non ha i denti che portiamo questo
proverbio nel mondo della tecnologia
il pane sono le idee per me i denti sono
le conoscenze le possibilità chi ha
tutte queste cose ha molto successo
nella vita di solito pensiamo ad esempio
al nostro caro amico di roma scanu un
genio ho avuto un sacco di successo però
per i comuni mortali come noi è un po
più complesso perché magari un'idea
bellissima ma non ho le conoscenze
tecniche per svilupparla e magari non ho
i soldi per svilupparla però fino a
qualche tempo fa l'unica possibilità del
comune mortale di andare a sviluppare
magari un prodotto elettronico era
andare da un libero professionista una
società di consulenza e dare la
cosiddetta commessa io dico guarda
vorrei realizzare questa idea non so
come si fa a mela in un mondo ideale
tutto perfetto però sappiamo che le
persone non sono sempre del tutto onesta
e quindi nel caso sia noi abbiamo
un'idea
particolarmente innovativa dobbiamo
cercare di proteggere la nostra idea
come possiamo proteggerla con i
cosiddetti nba che sono dei contratti
legali per non diffondere informazioni
sensibili
oppure tramite nel caso dei brevetti
bene per fortuna però com'è il mondo è
bello perché è vario
esistono delle persone che hanno avuto
la buona volontà di cercare di rendere
la tecnologia fruibile a chiunque e
quindi nella perfetta filosofia del plug
and play e nata una nuova tipologia di
hardware dell'hardware per la creazione
di hardware cioè consentire a chiunque
anche digiuno gli elettroni
dell'informatica di riuscire a dar vita
in qualche modo la propria idea
i due anni protagonisti in questo mondo
sono arduino ardere buy
per chi non conoscesse questi due
giocatori sono le aziende che fanno
praticamente delle piattaforme di
sviluppo per prototipazione rapida che
consentono di avere un gradino di
ingresso nel mondo dell'elettronica
dell'informatica assai più basso perché
appunto danno degli strumenti molto
semplici per fare delle cose molto
complesse vi faccio
un esempio perché fino a poco tempo fa
quindi prima che queste persone
sviluppassero questi tool per fare
queste cose in maniera semplice il
tipico programmatore che voleva magari
accendere spegnere un led collegare un
dispositivo programmabile dove andare
utilizzare un linguaggio non molto
comprensibile a chi non ha mai visto
l'informatica in vita sua
una roba di questo genere che diceva non
è che sia proprio autoesplicativa no e
quindi cosa cosa si è pensato si è
pensato che le persone creative di
solito non sono gli ingegneri quindi
abbiamo detto come possiamo fare a
insegnare alle persone creative che però
non hanno le conoscenze tecniche ad
esempio a programmare cerchiamo di
andare a mappare delle cose difficili in
maniera più semplice utilizzando ad
esempio parole di uso comune quindi
andando a utilizzare un linguaggio come
un linguaggio parlato standard vicino
all'utente se parlo inglese diciamo che
quello che c'è scritto su questo codice
non è così incomprensibile ad esempio
c'è questa scritta pin mode che diciamo
se un po di fantasia capisco l'inglese
significa che voglio andare utilizzare
un film che poi sarà contatto in
modalità output ok poi voglio andare a
scrivere qualcosa aspettare scrivere
qualcos'altro aspettare lupo magari
significa che voglio ripetere da per
sempre perfetto questo è stato molto
importante perché ha consentito di avere
uno sviluppo esponenziale di queste
piattaforme
poiché si sono generate delle community
molto forte fa forti fatte da persone
creative e tecnici che hanno messo
insieme alle loro competenze per andare
a sviluppare ulteriormente della
piattaforma e renderla sempre più
fruibile a tutti infatti appunto se
guardo il codice di prima complesso
magari inorridisco se guardo quell'altro
sono un po più contento è addirittura
dei bambini riescono a programmare con
questo linguaggio ai bambini come vi
spiegheranno anche poi nel corso di
questo ted sanno essere molto molto
creativi
diciamo che grazie anche a questo
utilizzo molto forte di questi
dispositivi
ci sono poi sviluppate delle altre
tipologie di piattaforme che sono le
piattaforme di crowdfunding sono sicuro
che conoscete
ad esempio in di gogo o kickstarter sono
delle piattaforme su cui avete a
disposizione la vetrina di internet per
esporre la vostra idea magari con un
progetto che può essere anche un render
deve essere per forza un prodotto fatto
e finito avere a disposizione appunto
questa vetrina proporre l'idea cercare
dei finanziatori che possono essere
aziende o privati che magari partire con
la vostra start up appunto come vi
dicevo prima se andate su questi siti
navigate cercate i prototipi vedete che
all'interno di queste piattaforme e di
questi prototipi ci sono quasi tutti le
tante forme arduino raspberry pari
appunto perché hanno delle community
molto forti e sono molto fa e semplici
da utilizzare
però dobbiamo riflettere un po su delle
cose perché noi abbiamo delle
aspettative altissime come clienti
rispetto a plug'n'play appunto come vi
ho detto io potete comprare una scheda
riunione ripa inizierà a fare delle cose
assurde
ok benissimo è vero non ve lo confermo
solo che noi dobbiamo considerare anche
il fatto che quando noi abbiamo a
disposizione delle cose che fanno delle
operazioni molto complesse in maniera
semplice
stiamo andando a metter su un sacco di
sovrastrutture per andare a mappare
queste cose complesse in maniera
semplice questo ovviamente introduce del
dell'over ed e bisogna tenere in
considerazione le aspettative del
cliente tipo ovviamente posso fare un
altro esempio con con wordpress noi cosa
abbiamo io non conosco niente dei siti
web vado compro mio dominici stallo
wordpress usa un editor grafico trascino
elementi in stallo plugin ho fatto un
sito web di cose con un programmatore
dei siti web
no ho usato uno strumento per darmi da
fare imparare delle cose nuove ma non
posso sicuramente definirmi un
programmatore di siti web
questo per dirvi cosa che queste
piattaforme di apprendimento di cose
nuove sono molto utili vanno sicuramente
utilizzate
però se appunto io voglio andare a
soddisfare le aspettative altissime del
cliente nel mondo del pug e bay per
andare a coprire tutti i corner che mi
devo rimboccare le maniche scendere nel
dettaglio dei tecnicismi e riuscire a
ottimizzare l'applicazione per evitare
appunto che ci sia qualcosa che non
funziona
[Applauso]
[Musica]